20 février 2002 il ya 20 ans ça y est
c'est l'inauguration de vulcania dans le
puy de dôme
ce parc dédié aux volcans si chère à
valéry giscard d'estaing alors président
de la région auvergne ouvre enfin les
portes après 12 ans de polémiques suite
de la polémique autour de vol kahniens
1990 début du projet à l'époque il ne
s'appelle pas encore vulcania mais
volkan ya cet homme le volcanologue
maurice krafft à une idée un peu folle
celle de créer un parc à thème centré
sur les volcans le chercheur est
ambitieux son but construire un
ascenseur au coeur même d'un volcan
inactif le puy-de-dôme il n'empêche que
descente suter de circuler sous le
puy-de-dôme et de ressortir au sommeil
sont pas intéressants d'autant plus
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une attraction au
pur et simple qui consiste à faire ça
mais qui a dit salle sous le plus
d'hommes nous explique comment les
volcans fonctionne et de façon sérieuse
mais très lente le projet suscite la
colère des opposants parmi eux un autre
volcanologue haroun tazieff
écoutez le il ne mâche pas ses mots on
va faire
mauvais disneyland pour abuser le
baugeois pour abuser le touriste pour
abuser celui dont on veut se tirer au
maximum la fin après la mort de maurice
krafft en 1991 volkan ya reste en
suspens valéry giscard d'estaing alors
président de la région auvergne reprend
l'idée à son compte de leur côté les
militants continuent de s'y opposer non
non non giscard losc non non pollution
tourisme de masse ou encore budget trop
élevé voilà les arguments des opposants
il faut diminuer le coût c'est pas
possible on est à 400 va être va monter
à 500 millions de francs mais où est ce
qu'on va c'est le tiers du budget
régional
ccc sadien pharaonique cette
organisation une bataille juridique
s'engage des plaintes sont déposées
toutes rejetées
1996 volkan yade devient vulcania et en
1997 après des années de retard les
travaux débutent non pas à l'intérieur
du puy de dôme mais à quelques
kilomètres du volcan
dans lequel
le chantier aussi prend du retard et
comme si ça ne suffisait pas en 2001
incident bien perturber les travaux on a
frôlé la catastrophe hier soir sur le
site du futur centre européen du
volcanisme vulcania une dalle de béton
s'effondre sans faire de victime
finalement vulcania ouvre ses portes le
20 février 2002
deux ans de retard
[Musique]